formar y aire Francia y Reino Unido
realizan operaciones de rescate buscan
sobrevivientes luego de que un bote que
transportaba decenas de migrantes
naufragara mientras cruzaba el Canal de
la Mancha el Primer Ministro británico
Richie sunak lamentó la pérdida de Vidas
señor presidente estoy seguro de que
toda la cámara comparten y pesar por el
naufragio de un pequeño bote en el Canal
de la Mancha las primeras horas de la
mañana y la Trágica pérdida de Vidas
humanas
sin embargo el hecho ocurre apenas Un
día después de que el gobierno británico
anunciara un nuevo acuerdo con la
Albania de donde provienen la mayoría de
los migrantes irregulares que cruzan el
canal para regresarlos a ese país
incluso quienes sean Víctimas de tráfico
de personas o esclavitud moderna con el
acuerdo Londres considera Albania como
un país seguro para que los migrantes
sean devueltos también anunció la
creación de una unidad de embarcaciones
para hacer frente a estos arribos
irregulares las aguas que separan a
Reino Unido y Francia Son una
migratorias más peligrosas del mundo
debido a Las bajas temperaturas sin
embargo el Canal de la Mancha es uno de
los cruces marítimos más transitados
según la organización internacional para
las migraciones al menos 205 personas
han muerto intentando cruzarlo desde
2014 y tan solo en lo ocurrido este año
43.000 personas llegaron a Reino Unido
por esta ruta